So to state this in logic, we first have to define what j is.
And we're going to use the other the, the there exists quantifier. And
that's represented by a backwards facing E. So there's going to exist some
position which we're going to call j. And it's going to be greater than one.
We've already taken care of the k squared's equal to one.
So it's going to be greater than one and it's up to, the length of Y.
And what must be the case is that the value in Y of the jth position.
At the jth position must be equal to the value in X at the first position.
In order to make use of this we're going to then use the three
segments that we have and define. And we're going to use a recursive definition
like we did before. And, but it's going to be in terms of these three segments.